ومن تل ابيب تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره
فاطمه خميسي للحديث معك فاطمه عن تلك
التظاهرات في تل ابيب وايضا امام منزل
نتنياهو في مدينه قيساريا جنوب حيف
التظاهرات خلفك تطالب بابرام صفقه
لتبادل صفقه مع حماس للافراج عن
المحتجزين
نعم صحيح يعني اذا ما اردنا ان نطلب من
المصور ايثار ابو غربي ان ينقل لنا صوره
المشهد هنا وسط مدينه تلبيب فاننا نتحدث
عن مئات الاسرائيليين في هذه اللحظات
يتظاهرون هنا في وسط مدينه تلبيب مطالبين
باقاله حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو والذهاب الى
انتخابات فوريه يقولون بان بنيامين
نتنياهو فشل في اداره هذه الحرب حرب
اسرائيل على غزه وك كما نشاهد يعني هنالك
حشود كبيره جدا تتجمر في هذه اللحظات وهذه
ليست المظاهره الوحيده نتحدث عن عدد من
المظاهرات في اماكن متفرقه في مدينه تلبيب
في مدينه حيفا وايضا لازالت المظاهرات
مستمره في محيط بيت رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو في زاريا منذ
ساعات الصباح نتحدث ايضا عن نصب الخيام في
محيط المنزل واغلاق المخارج من منزل
بنيامين نتنياهو هذا ياتي ضمن فعاليات
التصعيد تصعيد الاحتجاجات التي تقود
عائلات الاصفى
المحتجزين في غزه نتحدث عن رفع اللافتات
تطالب باقاله الحكومه فورا والذهاب الى
انتخابات يقولون بان شعب موحد فقط سياتي
عند انتخاب قياده جديده وهذه الصوره التي
ننقلها الان مباشره من مدينه تل ابيب تعكس
حال جزء من الشارع الاسرائيلي اكثر من 100
يوم مرت على حرب اسرائيل على غزه والان
نرى ان الشارع الاسرائيلي بات يغلي هذه
المظاهره كما ذكرت ليست المظاهره الوحيده
وفقط دقائق قليله على انطلاقها وبتنا نرى
ان المئات من الاسرائيليين يتجمعون في وسط
مدينه تل ابيب للضغط على حكومه بنيمين
نتنياهو للذهاب الى صفقه للافراج عن صلاح
الاسرى الاسرائيلي المحتجزين في غزه وايضا
نتحدث عن تصعيد في وتيره هذه الاحتجاجات
حيث يطالب هنا عدد من المحتجين باقاله
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وسبق ان طالب ايضا
وزير الدفاع الاسبق فيكتور ليبرمان باسقاط
هذه الحكومه والذهاب الى انتخابات فوريه
بادعاء ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه مسؤوله عن
الفشل الاستخبارات الذي حصل في السابع من
اكتوبر
وايضا عن مصير الاسر الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في غزه التقارير الامريكيه
الاخيره ايضا تشير نقلا عن مسؤولين
عسكريين اسرائيليين بانه لا يمكن على
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يقوم باعاده الاسرى
المحتجزين في غزه وايضا القضاء على حركه
حماس وهذه هي من احدى اهداف هذه الحرب وما
دفع الناطق العسكري باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالخروج في يوم السبت لنفي هذه التقارير
الامريكيه وبالتالي اذا ما اردنا ان نرى
هذه صوره فاننا نتحدث عن تصعيد في حركه
الاحتجاجات الاسرائيليه كمحاوله للضغط على
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو في وضع ملف الاسرى
المحتجزين في غزه كاولو لهذه الحكومه خاصه
وان هنالك خشيه في الاداره الامريكيه من
ان يقوم بنيامين نتنياهو في المماطله في
هذه الحرب وتطويلها وان يقوم
بالتنصل من الذهاب الى صفقه للافراج عن
صراح الاسرى الاسرائ
بهدف ارضاء الائتلاف الحكومه وشركاء في
الائتلاف وايضا
بهدف مصالحها الشخصيه والسياسيه فاطمه
يعني اشرت الى انه سرعان ما انضم المئات
الى هذه
التظاهر يعني بعد دقائق من بدئها ويتوقع
ايضا ان يكون هناك حشد اكبر في وقت لاحق
هل يتوقع كذلك ان ينضم او تنضم ش صيات
سياسيه لهذه التظاهر على غرار ما حصل
مؤخرا عندما انضم بني جانس الى احدى
تظاهرات اهالي
الاسرى صحيح حتى هذه اللحظه من غير
المعروف ان كان سيشارك في هذه المظاهره
شخصيات قياديه بارزه ولكن سبق ان ذكرت ان
وزير الدفاع الاسبق الاسرائيل فيكتور
ليبرمان يؤيد ما يتم طرحه في هذه المظاهره
من اقاله للحكومه الاسرائيليه والذهاب الى
انتخابات فوريه ولكن نحن نعلم ان لدى
اكدور ليبرمان خلاف شخصي مع بنيامين
نتنياهو وسبق ايضا ان شارك كما ذكرت
الوزير في مجلس الحرب بيني جنس في احدى
المظاهرات التي نظمتها عائلات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه ولكن حتى
هذه اللحظه نستطيع القول بان هذه المظاهره
يشارك فيها عدد من الجهات التي كانت فاعله
جدا في المظاهرات التي اقيمت ضد التعديلات
القضائيه مطلع العام السابق وضد حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو وبالتالي هذه الشخصيات لا
تزال بارزه على مستوى الحراك الشعبي
الاسرائيلي الرافض لحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
والان بدنا نرى ان المطالبات تتسع نتحدث
عن الذهاب الى صفقه لتبادل الاسرى واطلاق
صباح الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
غزه وايضا اسقاط هذه الحكومه والذهاب الى
انتخابات فوريه بحجه ان هذه الحكومه هي
مسؤوله عن ما حصل في السابع من اكتوبر
مسؤوله عن قتل عش را الاف الفلسطينيين في
قطاع غزه وبالتالي هذه الحكومه يصفون بان
خطر على مستقبل اسرائيل وخطر على مستقبل
الاسرائيليين طبعا الجهات اليمينيه تعارض
هذه الحكومه يصفونهم بانهم طابور خامس وان
هذه مثل هذه الاحتجاجات ليست بمناسبه خاصه
في وقت حساس تواجهه اسرائيل على المستوى
الامني ونتحدث عن حرب متعدده الجبهات حتى
هذه اللحظه كما ذكرت لا يوجد اي معلومه عن
وجود شخصي
بارزه اسرائيليا ولكن من المتوقع في ظل
استمرار هذه الاحتجاجات ان ينضم اليها
شخصيات ربما يكون لديها اثر على مستوى
اتخاذ القرارات خاصه وان ايضا العضو في
مجلس الحرب دي ايزن قال انه بنيامين
نتنياهو لا يولي اهميه لاعاده المختطفين
الاسرائيليين ربما هذه
الاحتجاجات يعني فعل ضغط اكبر على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه شكرا لك فاطمه خميسي مراسله
الجزيره من تلابي b